ni le froid ni la pluie n'auraiit pu
décourager ses fans de jeux vidéo hier à
Versailles ont fêté le lancement de The
Art of the swar la dernière extension du
jeu vidéo Starcraft 2 créé par la
société blizar pourquoi Versailles car
c'est ici que l'entreprise a installé
son siège européen et pour ses joueurs
c'était l'événement à ne pas manquer là
on attend depuis 1 heure 1 he30 quelque
chose comme ça mais c'est surtout les
conditions ouais il fait super froid
donc c'est un peu dur le premier jeu je
l'attendais depuis 10 ans à peu près là
bah je suis obligé d'être là pour la
deuxième quoi donc j'ai j'ai pris des
heures en moins sur mon taf mais bon
voilà des fans prêt à tout pour assister
à ce lancement planétaire une promotion
impressionnante et une stratégie
marketing au point les fans parfois
maquillés à l'effigie des personnages de
Starcraft sont rentrés dans le jeu entre
deux photos avec les héros on n'oublie
pas de passer par la case
souvenir c'est juste le petit plus qui
fera qu'on l'oubliera et il n'est pas
prêt d'oublier sa soirée car dans la
salle il y avait des stars en chair et
en os des joueurs professionnels comme
Stefano le jeune Français qui n'a pas
hésité à poser avec ses
admirateurs en tout quatre joueurs prêt
à s'affronter toute la soirée sur scène
à ce jeu de stratégie sur PC une guerre
sans merci sur une autre galaxie entre
les terranes les protos et les
erges attention le show commence dans un
anglais presque
parfait car cet événement mondial était
retranscrit en live sur internet le show
de Versailles suivait ceux de
l'Australie et de la Corée du Sud avant
de donner le relais aux
États-Unis